This ellipse would be centered at 2, negative 1. Nice work if you got the
center. The a value was 3, and the b value was 6. Even better if you got all
three correct. We know that the center is at 2, negative 1, since this is a
minus 2 and this is a positive 1. Since we subtract two from x, we really move
two units to the right from the origin. Then we move one unit down since
there's a plus 1 with the y term. Remember we move in the opposite direction of
what we think. So, now that we know the center is here, we can use the values
of a and b to get four other points. To get the value of a, we take the square
root of 9, which equals 3. And to get the value of b, we take the square root
of 36 which equals 6. We know that we need to move left 3 units and right 3
units from the center to get two other points on our ellipse. We can also move
six units up and six units down, to get two more points on the ellipse. Now if
you haven't quite got it, that's okay, try this next one.